all right before the break we detailed
much of the deep states dislike a
president Trump and over the weekend
former CIA director John Brennan
directed this revealing tweet at the
president when the full extent of your
venality moral turpitude and political
corruption becomes known you will take
your rightful place as a disgraced
demagogue and the dustbin of history you
may scapegoat Andy McCabe but you will
not destroy America America will triumph
over you
what bad writing is the FBI colluding
with the Intel community to destroy the
Trump presidency
well let's put that to the test retired
FBI assistant director Chris whackers
with us and retired FBI special agent
Terry Lane and Fox News contributor and
Washington Examiner reporter byron york
gentlemen we have so much to get through
we got it we got to be picky about this
I want to play for you right off the bat
this commentary this testimony by
Brennan on may 23rd of last year at the
house Intel committee let's watch
have you ever requested that a u.s.
person's name be unmasked
yes F are you aware of any requests
within the community that were denied I
do not I didn't have visibility into
requests that were being made across the
government so I don't I don't recall one
that I was denied okay so Chris
basically if you ask for someone to be
unmasked it's gonna get unmasked I mean
he could he kind of said I do not well I
don't know the whole range of what do
you make of that in light of what we
know now his tweet the focus on getting
Trump he's a demagogue that's a former
FBI director CIA director excuse CIA
director well clearly he was still
working for President Obama while he was
working for President Trump and I I have
never seen so much polluted
at the tops of these two agencies the
FBI and the CIA I it's something that I
hate to concede I hate to admit but
under director Comey clearly there was
an agenda to kill the Clinton email
investigation and not even let the
campaign finance or the foundation
investigation continue or be conducted
in a way that's designed to
to the truth of the matter so you've got
two things going on there I also think
however Laura that the special counsel
needs to exist and we need to get to the
bottom of some other things as well
biron john brennan I think showed in his
tweet this weekend just how much
animosity has built up like Chuck
Schumer warned against the president
Samantha Power's also has it had a
response not a good idea to piss off
John Brennan that's lovely language
coming from Samantha Power's to say they
got off on a bad foot is just an
incredible understatement go back to the
transition Donald Trump has been elected
the intelligence Chiefs are working on
their report about Russian meddling they
finish it in January 2017 they briefed
President Obama on it and they also
briefed President Obama about the
dossier and the salacious details in the
dossier so the next day January 6 they
go up to Trump Tower for him in there
including John Brennan and James Comey
and they talked to him about the report
on Russian interference and then by
prearrangement three of them leave
leaving Comey alone with the president
elect who tells him about the dossier
but call me knows the dossier is paid
for does he not at that point by fusion
GPS but fusion of GPS gets paid for by
we think by the Hillary Clinton I am
pain and we think that he does he tell
the president that not not to are not oh
god we really only know what Comey is
said but think of this from the
president elects point of view first
face-to-face meeting with the FBI and
they tell him by the way we know about
you and those hookers in Moscow so that
is getting off on a real NASA meant to
rattle the president meant to we were on
to you
we know how else could he think that Joe
digenova
was on radio today with me Terry and
he's coming in as a new lawyer on the
Trump team he's a longtime contributor
to this show and others on Fox and this
is what he said let's listen I really
believe that Brennan and clapper or the
people who are most most responsible for
all of the violations of law that
occurred during the
2016 campaign that involved not only the
unmasking but the illegal disclosures
and other things so in many ways this
this tweet by Brennan was was a blessing
in disguise Terry for that he's being
called again the conspiracy theorist
Donald Trump's hiring a conspiracy
theorist for one of his Nonna's legal
team and so forth your reaction well
Laura I'll tell you like we say in Texas
Brennan is an idiot he has no idea how
the FBI operates his agency operates
completely different although they take
an oath to the Constitution they don't
follow the Constitution as we have to
you know the FBI has to follow the
Constitution to the letter
you know whenever we prosecute somebody
whenever we investigate someone we have
to follow all the rules of evidence all
the criminal procedures the CIA doesn't
do that so I'm not surprised that
Brennan comes up with this this idiotic
statement that he makes
because again his sages he can operate
on conjecture his agency doesn't have to
follow the truth their stock and trade
is actually the untruths so you know I
don't know that there's a deep state but
if there is I am absolutely certain
Brennan's part of that deep state Kris
I'm gonna go back to you because you
wrote a piece for Fox News about how
truth-telling by the FBI but going back
to McCabe's firing here in the general
sense of lawlessness conflicts of
interest on ethical behavior the the
telling of the truth is so critical for
the FBI why and that's a sacrosanct
rule that must be followed and if it's
not breaks down the trust tell us well
certainly fidelity bravery integrity is
the FBI's motto and its integrity
because they have to testify about
things that they do they have people's
life liberty and property in their hands
they can put their thumb on the scale of
an investigation and deprive someone at
liberty in a second so they have to tell
the truth and they can't nuance the
truth and they can't spin it they have
to tell all you know the whole story the
way it comes out factually so and Andy
McCabe knew that
his own OPR OPR reported directly to him
Candace will the assistant director of
OPR was one of his direct reports she
basically fired her own boss because the
FBI was cleaning its own house here and
Byron I want to go back to you the
Michael Bromwich is a lawyer for mccabe
tweeted out we will not be responding to
each childish defamatory disgusting and
false tweet by the president the whole
truth will come out and do course but
the tweets confirm that he has corrupted
the entire process that led to mr.
McCabe's termination as rendered it
illegitimate illegitimate what can we
expect I think we need to look at people
who know something about this case and
even even Adam Schiff the Democrat on
the House Intelligence this firing was
proper and then he criticized the way in
which it was done but people who know
about this are being careful not to
denounce this as as an illegitimate sort
of act and we do know that the
nonpartisan parts of the FBI office
Professional Responsibility and the
inspector general were behind this last
thing
McCabe had a media tool ready before
this he had done several interviews with
media people and the one thing he did
not talk about what's the details of
what led to his firing interesting
interesting and we'll keep following
this all show long but we're out of time
unfortunately I'll have you back there's
gonna be going on all week next week as
well